more and more people taking to the sky
as cova 19 restrictions continue to ease
it's nice to be able to travel again and
and do things with your family after
being home for two years and come monday
traveling in and out of the country is
set to get a bit easier for some with
restrictions loosening again welcome
news for erica suterman and her family
she and her husband traveled to mexico
in march while testing requirements were
still in effect for returning to canada
a reason why they left their two
children at home i think the reason we
didn't take the kids was because i
didn't want to have to worry about them
you know getting coveted and having to
test and come home and my kids don't
like taking a test so it was just such a
you know we didn't want to take them for
that reason travel agencies also
welcoming the news and they expect to
see another uptick in canadians
traveling that pre-flight test has been
expensive and it's also been a hassle
with this round of restrictions being
eased
that's really where i notice a lot more
families excited to start to travel but
fewer barriers for travelers can also
mean fewer barriers for transmission of
the virus remember that the more that
mandates and restrictions are dropped
the more that gives us the opportunity
to be mobile to get around
to be around more people and of course
that's what the virus likes
epidemiologists say travelers should
research both levels of restrictions and
levels of risk at their vacation
destination
and with the u.s dropping mask mandates
for air and train travel amid rising
cases now is the time to take extra
precaution i would strongly encourage
people
to be wearing a well-fitted mask and to
wear it consistently and suderman plans
on doing just that as she looks ahead to
planning a trip to mexico this time for
the entire family i would definitely
want our trip to be
uh covet-free so masking all the way
marty blunt global news winnipeg